brings the knight back where it came
from so eric does have the opportunity
to bring the black rook back to the
center uh but that would only okay he
does repeat the position this is the
second time we've seen this position if
the position repeats itself for a third
time that's a draw so essepenko is he
can continue his winning attempts
it is tricky if you try too hard as
white that black rook is just going to
mop up all your pawns
and the seconds are ticking down and so
yeah he does try again so he retreats
the knight again tries to maintain
okay so now black does have the look at
eric he's got the opportunity if he
brings his rook back where it came from
to the e1 square it's a draw that's the
third time we've seen the position
if he doesn't that will involve some
risk and eric looking off to the side
essepenko's still full of adrenaline
yeah look at him
it's a draw though eric does bail out
what so many twists and turns in that
game but it is a draw
wow what a game and it ends eventually
in a draw